foreign
Carr live where the news has literally
just broken that Cristiano Ronaldo has
left Manchester United with immediate
effect now ever since Ronaldo shook the
world with that Sensational interview
with our own Piers Morgan right here on
talk TV it is the news I guess we've all
been waiting for I'm about to be joined
by the man who made it happen the man
who got that exclusive everyone wanted
but before that here's what Christiana
said to peers on completely uncensored
they're trying to force you out yes not
only the coach but the other two or
three guys there around
the club
at the senior executive level yes that I
felt betrayed
and you think they're trying to get rid
of you honestly I shouldn't say that I
don't know but listen I I don't care I'm
always people should listen the truth
yes I feel betrayed and I felt that some
people that don't want me here not only
this year but last year too
it's close to the sons who cares wins
the world live tonight in London to
peers how are you my friend
um you must have known this was going to
happen after that amazing interview last
week
yeah I'm not surprised uh I'm surprised
perhaps at the speed that has happened
um but I'm not surprised that Cristiano
is now leaving Manchester United it
seems by Mutual consent obviously I
doubt that would have happened without
the interview so it's had huge
consequences but I think that he will be
happy that he's now free to pursue his
career elsewhere with a club which
hopefully will serve him a bit more
respect than the current ownership and
Executives at Manchester United showed
him peers um how much contact have you
had since that interview last week did
you have an inkling about timing or
where he might go
no I've been in daily contact with
Cristiano just to make sure that he's
okay with everything as it's all rolled
out it's entirely how he wanted it to be
he wanted to have his say he knew what
he wanted to say he's the greatest
football player that's ever played the
game he's the biggest sporting icon in
the world he just passed you know half a
billion Instagram followers this week
and he's at the World Cup so it's the
biggest possible stage with the biggest
sporting icon at the center of a huge
drama he's used to that he's used to
drama and I think that he was just fed
up with the way he's been treated simple
as that and Manchester United I mean if
the fans are happy they've lost
Cristiano Ronaldo they need their their
minds checking because he remains to me
one of the best strikers in the world I
mean this sticks in my gullet having to
ask this question but I'm guessing uh
you'd love him at Arsenal wouldn't you
to cement the the the the the Sprints to
the Premiership title is that right
well I would actually like him at
Arsenal I think we need a proven
world-class goal scorer to add to this
squad with Five Points clear in the
league we will be until after Christmas
now because of the World Cup Cristiano
Ronaldo for the rest of the season
leading our line with Gabrielle Jesus
yes please if he's a free agent let's
get him why not you might be able to
make it happen let's be honest you made
it happen last week and I just say to
people watching you can get that entire
interview on YouTube it is an absolute
exclusive
um peers you said you're not surprised
you said he's okay
um Manchester United surely are going to
look back at this having lost the most
iconic player a player that just has
transcended almost every other player in
the game and regret the way they've
treated him won't they
I would think so I mean you've got Eric
tenhag the manager he's never managed
outside of of Holland he's never
succeeded outside of Holland and I think
he's conspired with the way he's treated
Ronaldo to drive out one of the great
Legends of the club and a man who last
season scored 24 goals including 18 in
the Premier League which is one more
than Harry Kane the captain of England
in the World Cup who is by Common
consent one of the best strikers in the
world you don't lose that ability in
four months so Ronaldo I think has been
mucked around by 10 harg I think he's
been treated with a lack of empathy by
United's Executives particularly over
the very difficult things he's had to
endure his his personal life with the
loss of his baby's son and then his
daughter who survived that awful time
and then having uh being hospitalized at
the end of July and and I think that you
know he just wanted metaphorically that
people put their arms around him and
show him a bit of respect and instead
they've just been reveling it seems to
me and trying to humiliate you which I
just don't understand do you do you get
the sense or did you get the sense when
you spoke to him that there there was
fear that this might tarnish his legacy
the fans every fan I've spoken to uh is
is is devastated and quite understanding
a large majority of of how he felt and
why she'd have his say was he was he
scared of giving it or he reached a
point the way he was being that he had
no other option
no I think he loves United fans he
certainly doesn't want to fall out with
them he's not the first United Legend to
speak out Roy Keane left Manchester
United when he spoke out on Manchester
United TV so he's still revered by the
fans I think Time Is A Healer with these
things I'm sure United fans who know
about their football will remember the
Cristiano Who lit up the team for all
those years when he was a teenager and
into his twenties uh and he came back
last season and was by far the best
player of the season so it's only been
in the last you know two or three months
of this season that things have
unraveled and they've unraveled because
he has a coach who uh mistreats him in
my opinion I mean you know it all goes
back to things like
the way that he didn't bring him on
against Manchester City and said he did
so out of respect for Cristiano what
he'd achieved in the game and then the
next game he asked him to come on with
three minutes left and that sparked an
incident which Ronaldo regrets where he
refused to come on but he's like which
player in the world of his magnitude
would come on for the last three minutes
of a game you're winning two nil it was
insulting it was disrespectful it
wouldn't have happened to Lionel Messi
or Thierry on Marie at his pomp or the
other Ronaldo or any Zinedine zazan so
why do it to to Cristiano Ronaldo I
think he was done deliberately to show
Ronaldo whose boss
um but I'm not sure that was a good
tactic they lost him now and good luck
to a team who gets him well I was going
to say absolutely pal and thank you and
thank you from all of us here because
that interview was extraordinary as I
said you can still see it on YouTube
Piers Morgan uh on later from eight
having his say thank you very much to
DPS um just to actually read the quote
um Cristiano Ronaldo is to leave man
united about mutual agreement with
immediate effect we've said that the
club thanks him for his immense
contribution across two Spells at Old
Trafford they've issued that statement
he added the following following
conversations with man united we have
mutually agreed to end our contract
early I love Manchester United and I
love the fans and that will never ever
change however it feels like the right
time for me to seek a new challenge can
I just remind you it was the interview
that everybody wanted it was the
interview that Piers Morgan on talk TV
got and you can still see it on YouTube
seriously give it a look